[Music]
do you need another key for your honda
vehicle maybe you have a single key
perhaps you bought the vehicle and it
came with only one key maybe you've lost
one send it through the washing machine
or maybe your key is broken and falling
apart like this or maybe you just uh
have more drivers and need additional
keys
anyway i'm mike with tom's key company
i'm super excited to tell you about the
new simple key product for honda
vehicles inside the box it'll come with
this little programming device and
another key if you need extra keys we
sell additional ones on the website as
well so visit tomsky.com where you can
pick one up but first let me show you
how easy this is to use when you get
your simple key kit the first thing
you'll notice is that your new key
hasn't been cut yet to match your
existing one
so you can go find a dealership or a
locksmith
that'll do that for you or you can make
your life even easier
and use tom's key companies key by photo
service it's super easy
add that to your order
and once you check out you'll submit
photos of your existing key
we'll use proprietary technology to
replicate the cuts on your existing key
and put it onto this new key so it
arrives in the mail cut and ready to
program
okay now in your box you have the easy
installer that communicates with the
vehicle computer heads up the printed
manual is going away instead easy to
follow online instructions are being
rolled out so grab a smartphone and it
will walk you through each step of the
key pairing process there's a frequently
asked questions section that solves
common problems and if you're still
having trouble you can call technical
support also at tom's key company we
provide a full money back guarantee so
if it fails and you can't get it to work
we'll give you your money back just
reach out to us via email help
tomsky.com and we can take care of you
okay so in order to begin
you need to
turn to the dial position indicated in
the table
position number one for this honda
accord that we're working on today we're
going to take our working key and it's
important to note you must have a
working key that starts the vehicle to
use our programming equipment you'll
know which one i have working because
i've got this tile key finder on it you
might want to pick one of these up on
our website it pairs to your smartphone
and then you can always find your keys
in case you lose them okay to begin
we're going to take our working key
and put it in turn two clicks to the on
position
don't start the engine
then we're going to take the
easy installer and plug it into the obd2
port
come down by your gas and brake pedal
look up
you're looking for the obd2 plug like
this
just come and plug it in
[Music]
you'll hear the programmer beep so you
know it's plugged in now i need to take
and press the button
on the end of our programmer
we heard the programmer beep
when it beeps twice you turn the
ignition off and we remove the working
key
it beeped once now we're going to insert
our new key
and turn it to the on position don't
start the engine
it beeped twice
that lets us know we can turn the
ignition off do not remove the key
it beeps
turn the ignition on
don't start the engine
now wait 10 seconds we're listening for
it to beep twice
you might notice a blinking green light
okay there it beeped twice
turn the ignition off it'll beep again
turn the ignition on still leaving the
same new key in the ignition
and you hear the tune that let us know
it's successful
so we're going to turn the engine off
unplug the programmer and check that it
works
okay here we go
there we go wasn't that easy starts the
engine
let's check the remote buttons make sure
they work
lock
unlock
trunk and there's the panic
okay
it's that easy now i also want to
mention uh the instructions tell you all
about this but if early in the
programming process
the programmer beeps seven times
that means your vehicle already has the
maximum number of keys programmed to it
six keys on this on these honda vehicles
never fear the instructions
teach you how to erase
all except one working key and then you
can follow the same procedure to program
your new keys plus any additional keys
that you may have had before so there
you've seen just how easy it is to use
this simple key programmer to make
yourself new keys for honda vehicles go
visit tomsky.com where you can pick up
this simple key kit for your honda and
make keys and save a ton of money over
the cost that the car dealership charges
and if you're looking for other vehicles
we probably have a kit for that as well
we look forward to helping you make new
keys
hope you have a great day